hi I'm Sadashiva PI from science mission
today we have dr. Rochelle Hines from
universities of Nevada with us she has
won several awards in 20 2007 she won
the senior graduate fellowship
studentship from Michael Smith
foundation for Health Research in 2009
she won postdoctoral fellowship from
Canadian Institute of Health Research in
2011 she won the pilot project award
Center for Neuroscience research Duff
University in 2017
she won faculty research mentor award
from the office of undergraduate
research at UNLV
so welcome dr. Hines thank you very much
so can you talk please talk about your
background interest and some research
aspect of faith yeah sure so my
background is in neuroscience I got my
bachelor's degree in neuroscience as
well as my PhD and then did a postdoc
after that at Tufts University in Boston
my PhD and my bachelor's degree were
earned in Canada I'm originally from
Canada so you'll probably notice my
accent as we talk today a little bit yep
and tell us about your lab and grad
students postdocs just briefly yeah I'm
really lucky to have a great
collaborator who also happens to be my
husband so we actually run our labs as a
group collective and between the two
labs we have six graduate students and a
number of undergraduate students we
don't yet have senior people postdocs
but we're hoping that that's right
around the corner okay and how do you
motivate these students I think a good
motivator is leading by example try to
show an example of hard work and it's
hard for me to contain my enthusiasm
sometimes for projects so I think that
can be a bit contagious too I'm always
really excited about what we're working
on and moving things forward and trying
to get to the next steps so okay can you
please talk about people role models
makers in your career yeah I've had a
lot of really great mentors so the labs
that I worked in through my training dr.
Jeff climb doctor Allah al husseiny and
dr. Steven Moss have all been really
influential I think Allah is
particularly influential for me because
while I was a graduate student he passed
away and so that was kind of a really
polarizing event and I often kind of
think of you know what advice he would
be giving me if you were still here and
I'm also really motivated and guided by
women in science it's kind of a passion
of mine successful women in science and
so I look to a lot of the kind of you
know more classic role models like
Brenda Milner and Rita levi-montalcini
but also look to a lot of my
contemporaries who are you know doing
really incredible work really advancing
neuroscience research okay so let's just
briefly talk about what else you her
interests are other than the research
like hobbies and I know you have a
couple of small children yeah yeah well
I'm uh I grew up in Canada right next to
the Canadian Rockies so I'm kind of an
outdoors person we do a lot of hiking
backpacking rock climbing and Las Vegas
is a great spot for that because there's
a lot of you know parks within the day's
Drive we do a lot of outdoor trips okay
and coming back to your research what
made you get interested in neuro
development um so I actually started
with my undergraduate degree thinking
about heading into special education and
at the time I was working in schools
with kids with autism and I kind of
became frustrated because I felt like we
didn't even really understand the
fundamentals about what was happening
for these kids you know we didn't really
understand what was going on inside
their brains we didn't really
understand the pathophysiology and so I
got really interested in kind of trying
to learn more and then I just kind of
fell in love with neuroscience okay so
how does it that you are current what we
just do whatever your instincts can you
please go ahead and present your work
whenever you get a chance okay
yeah um so today I'm gonna be talking
about research focusing on GABAergic
synapses and um let's see and forgetting
and I really got interested in GABAergic
synapses seeing the powerful role that
GABA plays in development and so that's
been kind of an ongoing topic for me is
looking at inhibitory synapse
development and how this contributes to
some of the pathologies like
neurodevelopmental disorders and we'll
touch on some of that today okay um so
the title for my talk is GABAergic
signaling at the axon initial segment
you can see the slides well yeah okay
perfect
so first I'll kind of talk about why
brain development is actually such a
complex task
we know that disorders of the brain are
actually of brain development are
actually quite prevalent there is more
than 4.6 million children affected in
the United States and they're quite
heterogeneous there's a number of you
know subtly different disorders that
kind of get grouped together and also
many of them are polygenic so there's
autism for example has about 65 genes
that are strongly linked and more than
200 others that have weaker links so it
is quite complex in terms of you know
how these disorders comes come to be but
we can actually gain quite a bit of
benefit by looking at what's common
among them and so we do see that there's
common symptom profiles so things like
impaired social skills problems with
communication repetitive behaviors and
also things like sensory hyper arousal
and epilepsy an epilepsy is particularly
interesting to me
it's comorbid um across a number of
different neurodevelopmental disorders
and we also know that there are some
overlapping genetic contributors and
what we see is that a number of genes
involved in synapse formation and
control of the formation of neuronal
circuitry actually are represented
across multiple neurodevelopmental
disorders so we do actually understand
the great deal about how to set up the
cortex for example and you know a lot of
really elegant work over many years of
research has shown the steps involved in
you know developing new cells and having
them migrate up the radial glial
processes sending out their own
processes and developing synapses and
although we understand all of this kind
of very well as a model the trouble with
building a brain is that it doesn't
really look like this it actually looks
a lot more like this and what we can see
here in this really beautiful image from
the brain Brainbow to project is that
it's really really complex the cells
have complex morphologies they have a
number of interacting partners and those
partners need to be very highly
specified and in this image we're just
seeing just a tiny portion of the cortex
and not even we're just seeing only
neuronal cells we're not even seeing the
non-neuronal cells here so this gives
you kind of a glimpse into why it is so
hard to set this up perfectly every time
and if we kind of step back out to a
model level we can actually see that
there's a lot of different types of
cells that make up the cortical
circuitry and they all have their own
kind of layers in which they reside they
have unique morphologies and they have
very specific patterns of connectivity
and it's really important that we have
this high fidelity wiring during
development in order to have normal
cortical function so in typical
development we virtually never see a
mess
take the right synopsis always form on
the right targets and everything
proceeds as normal but subtle
modifications to this can lead to
disordered states like disorders of
development and when we do have
appropriate wiring we get the generation
of patterned activity and so you know
everybody's heard the term brainwaves
that's something that I'm really
interested in in my research are these
patterns of activity these brainwaves
that we can record using
electroencephalography and underlying
normal States we see very kind of
characteristic patterns and if we kind
of disrupt the pattern moving into
epilepsy we can see that activity runs
out of control and we see high amplitude
and repetitive firing of cells and this
leads to visible seizures and then kind
of on the other end of the spectrum we
can sees kind of slowing of the
oscillatory activity underlying sleep
states like sleep and anesthesia and
eventually if we slow it down enough
where you can see highly pathological
states like coma and so the way that we
kind of pattern activity is really
important for supporting different
functional states in different states of
arousal and we know that the peaks in
the EEG are characterized by on signals
or excitation and so this peak here
would represent a large population of
neuronal cells firing in relative unison
and where we see these troughs in the
EEG these are characterized by off
signals or inhibition and if we didn't
have in abyssion we wouldn't see this
kind of shaping of the activity we
wouldn't see this development of
patterning and so again many years of
research has kind of demonstrated that
patterning of activity is really
powerfully shaped by synaptic inhibition
and the primary inhibitory
neurotransmitter in the brain is gaba
and so here's a look at an inhibitory
synapse in an electron micrograph what
you can see all these little circles
here are the pre synaptic vesicles they
contain gaba that's going to be released
on to this postsynaptic compartment here
which in this case actually happens to
be a shaft of the dendritic spine or aft
of a dendrite sorry not a spine and here
we're looking at a cartoon of this kind
of same sort of inhibitory synapse so
here we have the presynaptic terminal
with these vesicles filled with gaba
and then gaba is released into the cleft
and it crosses and binds to postsynaptic
receptors that we're going to talk about
in a few minutes
um gaba is really fascinating to me
because it does play some key roles
early in development it's actually the
first neurotransmitter during
development and it plays roles in
guiding cells to the appropriate layer
and also in promoting their maturation
and so in terms of trying to understand
neuro development gaba seems to be a
really good place to start given that it
plays all these really critical roles
gaba also controls these unique
developmental oscillations called giant
depolarizing potentials and that's
because early in development gaba is
actually depolarizing because the
chloride gradient is not yet set up to
be high outside of neuronal cells and
then as gaba becomes hyper polarizing as
it looks in its in the mature nervous
system we see that these giant
depolarizing potentials disappear
but this also creates a seizure
sensitive context and we can see that
there's a very high incidence of
seizures in development and also in
neurodevelopmental disorders so here
we're looking at the incidence per every
100,000 you can see that it's highest in
the first ten years of life and goes
down and then later in life it goes back
up again for a number of reasons but
we're just kind of focusing on this area
here we're very early in life we see
this relatively high incidence of
seizure disorders and then if we look at
the intersection between
neurodevelopmental disorders like autism
Rett syndrome Angelman syndrome we can
see a lot of things in common including
a relatively high incidence of seizures
in these disorders um so now we'll talk
a little bit about the postsynaptic
target of gaba because the postsynaptic
compartment is one way to possibly
modulate GABAergic signaling so again
when gaba is released from the
presynaptic terminal it crosses the
cleft and binds to postsynaptic
receptors and the most common
postsynaptic receptor for gaba is the
GABA a receptor and it's a ligand gated
chloride channel and again because the
chloride is normally high outside of
neuronal cells in maturity opening the
GABA receptor channel most commonly
results in hyper polarization of the
postsynaptic cells so chloride will move
in and bring negative charge with it
gabart gaba receptors are also super
interesting because they're the site of
action for a number of clinically
important drugs like benzodiazepines
arbitrates general anesthetics and also
sites of action for alcohol and many
neuro steroids gaba receptors are super
heterogeneous they're hetero penta MERS
and they're composed of 19 possible
subunits the most common gaba-a
receptors contain two alphas two betas
and a gamma subunit and again they're
over a number of years of research we've
really learned that the subunit
composition influences both the function
and the localization of these receptors
so in terms of function we can see
differences in the sensitivity to gaba
and other ligands and also in things
like decay time and in terms of
localization we can see that these
different types of receptor compositions
actually end up at different types of
synapses so there's also diversity in
the subtype of inhibitory synapses
and we see actually a kind of incredible
diversity in the different types of
interneurons and they all have their own
pattern of connectivity so each of these
colored cells is a different type of
gaba releasing cell called an inter
neuron and when these cells release GABA
they have a number of different effects
on the postsynaptic cell so here we can
see a cell that targets the dendrites
and because of the decremental nature of
graded potentials these have a
relatively local effect but we can also
see synopsis here on the soma and some
that occur right on the axon initial
segment and because these are very close
to or at the site of action potential
generation we have they kind of exert a
lot more powerful control over the
patterning of activity from these
parameter cells and these inhibitory
synapses right on the action axon
initial segment have kind of captured my
attention for a long time I first got
interested than in the Meza member
graduate because I was looking a lot at
electron microscopy and I was fascinated
by these very unique synapses that were
coming on to the exon initial segment
and here's just a really beautiful
picture of this specialized type of
inter neuron called the Chandeleur cell
and it's colored in red here and it
sends out this external projection that
branches and terminates on the axon
initial segment of large populations of
pyramidal cells so this one chandelier
cell is potentially signaling to huge
groups of pyramidal cells all at once
acting to hyperpolarize or inhibit them
and in this way we could see that this
cell type in particular might have
really powerful control over the phasing
and the coordination of activity of
cortical cells and here we're looking
again an electron micrograph this is
much like the images that kind of
captivated me as a student here's the
cell body coming down here and the axon
and you can see a number of inhibitory
is occurring right onto the axon initial
segment here so some of the overarching
questions of my work are how are these
functionally diverse GABAergic synapses
specified during development what role
might they play in neurodevelopmental
disorders and specifically I'm
interested in how GABAergic synapses on
the AIS develop what role GABAergic is
signaling plays and regulating
developmental activity patterns and
again kind of the functional
implications for any dysregulation that
we might see and so really what we set
out to do in these experiments is to
perturb GABAergic signaling at the axon
initial segment so the first thing that
we started working on is what is unique
about alpha 2 and how do all the two
containing receptors end up getting
enriched at the axon initial segment
because they do seem to have this
preferential localization there and so
here's a look at a sequence comparison
between alpha 1 on top and alpha 2 on
bottom and every time there's a red -
here you can see that means it's
identical between the two subunits and
hopefully you can see there's a lot of
red dashes except in this one segment
here and this actually represents a
portion known as the large intracellular
loop and it lies between transmembrane
domains 3 & 4 and so because alpha 2
ends up at the axon initial segment
preferentially an alpha one ends up
there with a much lower frequency we
became interested as to whether this
portion may be responsible for that
preferential targeting and in
collaboration with hans merrick and
herman shenlin we were able to
demonstrate that there's a specific
interaction for the alpha 2 subunit with
kali biston and for a long time it was
thought that jeff ron was the
preferential interacting partner with
alphas 1 through 3 but again we see kind
of a reciprocal preference for
interaction between alpha 2 and kali
biston
and then Jeff Hren is a preferential
interactor for alphas 1 and 3 and so
that's included in our recent paper they
did a you know a lot of really beautiful
work to demonstrate the strength of this
interaction so once we knew that that
portion was specific for interacting
with Kali biston we wanted to kind of
see if we could disrupt that interaction
and also disrupt the axon initial
segment localization so we generated an
alpha 2 alpha 1 chimera and we were able
to show that it does not interact with
Kali biston here using Amina
precipitation and we were also able to
show in a separate set of studies that
these chimeras don't actually reach the
axon initial segment at the same rate so
here's an image of the axon initial
segment and these are clusters of the
normal alpha 2 loop and then here's when
we substitute this portion with alpha 1
we can see a dramatic reduction in the
clusters on the axon initial segment so
next we set out to really investigate
what functional impact losing all the
two containing receptors might have on
the AIS and on just kind of function in
general in order to do that we generated
a mouse model and one of the first
questions that we wanted to investigate
is whether GABAergic synapses would
still be present on the axon initial
segment even in the absence of alpha 2
containing gaba receptors so here's a
look at the mouse that we generated so
wild-type mice will have a normal alpha
2 subunit and then the mice be generated
we called gaba 2-1
and they have a small substitution in
the large intracellular loop this is
about 13 amino acids from alpha one
that's been substituted into alpha 2 so
everything else about the subunit looks
identical except for these 13 amino
acids we can test for the validity of
our model using a loop antibody so this
antibody is specific for the alpha 2
loop and we can see in heterozygous
animals the bound for the for the loop
is reduced and in homozygous animals
it's
completely absent but interestingly
enough when we use an antibody against
the c-terminus about the two we see
actually that total expression of alpha
2 is increased
so again heterozygous animals have a
mild increase in alpha 2 expression and
homozygous animals have a relatively
strong increase in alpha 2 expression
and down here we started to look at some
of the other interesting targets
including Jeff Hren and Kali biston and
what we found is that Jeff wren remains
relatively unchanged and again this is
an agreement with the idea that Jeff
Rand is probably not interacting as
strongly with alpha 2 in comparison to
alphas 1 & 3
whereas Kali biston would be the
preferential partner and again in
heterozygous and homozygous animals we
see a significant decrease in the
expression of Kali biston in
collaboration with Jean Marc Ritchie's
lab we also did a lot of
immunohistochemistry to look at a number
of different subunits as well as a
number of different inhibitory proteins
but I'm just gonna highlight a couple of
here so here's confirmation that the
outfit total alpha 2 expression is
increased so normally in wild-type
animals we have you know a kind of
moderate level of puncta and in both
heterozygous and homozygous animals we
can see an increase in the the density
of puncta but we do see a decrease in
size and we also stain for Kali biston
and were able to see that in agreement
with the Western blotting data we see a
reduction in both heterozygous and
homozygous animals in terms of Kali
biston cluster size and Kali biston
cluster density we did a lot of
investigation about the total number of
inhibitory synapses and we found that
the total number of the gap puncta
wasn't changing but we wanted to see if
there might be a specific loss on the
axon initial segment and so we started
out in neurons that were cultured from
either wild-type or homozygous animals
and what we found is that in wild-type
animals we could see clusters about the
two on the AIS but when we looked at the
gabbro 2-1 homozygous cultures we saw a
loss of the
alpha-2 containing clusters and we've
been able to validate this in the animal
model as well so here we're looking at
an axon initial state segment stained
with beta four spectra and green and
we're looking at V gap positive
inhibitory synapses on on that axon
initial segment in red and you can see
that the inhibitory synapses kind of
occur throughout the length of the beta
for spectrum in wild-type animals but we
really don't see that accumulation in
the mutant animals so next we wanted to
see what influence this loss of synapses
onto the AAS might have on postnatal
development and one thing that we
actually noticed right away is that a
proportion of the gabbro 2-1 pups were
dying during postnatal development and
so we started kind of plotting and
tracking you know how many pups were
dying and at what age and of what
genotype and so here we're looking at
the proportion found dead across the
lifespan between zero and 120 days of
age you can see that very few animals
die in the first five to ten days of
life and we see a peak of mortality
somewhere around postnatal day 20 and
then it tapers off again and stays
relatively low throughout the rest of
the lifespan we can see a similar thing
here looking at this survival plot from
heterozygous by homozygous mating pairs
so each litter starts at a hundred
percent and then as animals die the line
drops down and we can see that again we
have this clustering of animals dying
somewhere around the age of postnatal
day 20 we also analyze the genotypes of
animals that were dying and we found no
wild-type animals were dying so that was
reassuring that we were looking at
something specific to the mutation and
we also found that looking at cumulative
mortality over time both heterozygous
and homozygous animals have the same
cumulative mortality
but homozygous animals seem to kind of
die earlier in development with
heterozygous animals being pretty fixed
right around postnatal day 20 what we
also started observing during that
period of time was the incidence of
spontaneous seizures and so here's
looking at Racine scores for a handful
of the spontaneous seizures that we
observed and so a Racine score is just a
behavioral method of scoring seizures we
were able to see that many of the
seizures that these animals were
experiencing were of highest severity
and they were happening right in the age
range that the animals were starting to
appear dead so we also got interested in
what influenced axon initial synapse
loss would have in mature animals
because interestingly not all of the
animals died and in fact a relatively
small number of animals are actually
able to be observed having seizures so
we wanted to see in in those animals
that do survive you know what's going on
in terms of their function and so we had
a close look at their surviving gapper
2-1 mice and we found that they had
normal growth so they weren't subject to
some sort of failure to thrive or other
you know gross developmental deficit and
we also did a Sherpa screen and so this
is just a basic screen of sensory motor
and reflexive function overall health
and we found that the heterozygous and
homozygous animals did not significantly
differ from wild-type animals on the
total Sherpa score and we also put the
animals through a number of tests like
the rotor rod to examine their motor
function and we also put them in the
open field that's the data shown down
here this is looking at the cumulative
distance traveled while the animals are
in the open field and also the average
speed at which they travel while they're
in the open field and we didn't see any
differences there
this gave us some confidence that we
could possibly examine other phenotypes
that might be of interest in the mature
animals alpha-2 is also highly
implicated in anxiety and alpha-2
containing receptors are thought to be a
primary mediator of the anxiety effects
of benzodiazepines and so anxiety was
kind of tops on our list for something
to examine we use two different tests of
anxiety we use the light dark boxes and
the elevated plus maze test and the
premise here is that rodents will prefer
to be in a relatively safe enclosed dark
compartment in comparison to a brightly
lit exposed compartment and again the
premise is similar here where we assume
that rodents will want to spend time in
these enclosed arms where they feel
safer as opposed to venturing out on
these open arms and so in each of these
tasks we're looking at the amount of
time spent in the different areas to try
to get a readout or an index of how
anxious the animals are and so normally
in the light dark box wild-type animals
will spend about maybe 90 90 seconds in
the light and when we compare that to
the heterozygous and homozygous animals
we see a significant reduction in the
amount of time that both heterozygous
and homozygous animals want to spend in
this brightly lit compartment and
similarly in the elevated plus maze we
see wild-type animals normally have
about maybe like a 25/75 split in terms
of time spent they spend most of their
time on the closed arms and about 25% of
their time in the open arms and when we
compare this to heterozygous and
homozygous animals we can see that both
groups are spending significantly less
time in the open arms and preferring to
spend their time in the closed arms of
the maze we also were interested in what
influenced this
so bas synapses would have on
oscillatory activity in the adult
animals again you know that was one of
our original ideas is that if we impair
GABAergic signaling on to the exon
initial segment we might impair the
patterning of activity and so we did EEG
analysis in the Gabbard 2-1 mice and we
use a pinnacle system and implant
animals with a small head mount and then
attached them to a tethered recording
system and this is just kind of an
example of the types of recordings that
we get from wild-type and heterozygous
animals and we commonly analyze these
complex waves using fast Fourier
transform and also spectral analysis so
we divide them into different frequency
bands Delta Theta alpha and gamma in
particular and then have a look at how
these bands differ across the different
genotypes and again we know that the
slower oscillations like Delta underlie
things like sleep whereas these fast
oscillations underlie things more like
working memory or active engagement in
the task and so down here we're looking
at a comparison between wild-type and
heterozygous animals and this is a
spectrogram plotting time frequency as
well as power and power is represented
by the intensity of the color and what
you can see is down here in this low
frequency portion heterozygous animals
have much higher power and we can see
that represented in the past for you
transform over here as well so wild-type
animals are here and heterozygous
animals have much higher power
especially in this kind of low frequency
Delta band and here's looking at average
Delta power between wild-type and
heterozygous animals you can see that
significantly increased so in
collaboration with AstraZeneca we were
also able to test some novel compounds
to see if we could normalize some of the
consequences of a is synapse dysfunction
and so we had a look at these novel
selective benzodiazepines and these are
benzodiazepine compounds so they bind to
the benzodiazepine site but they're
specific either for alpha 2 or alpha 1 3
and so we tested a compound called AZ d7
3 to 5 that's an alpha 2 selective
benzodiazepine like drug or positive
allosteric modulator and again here
we're looking at the elevated plus maze
paradigm and what we can see is that we
have vehicle treated diazepam treated
and azd treated animals here and we're
comparing wild-type in white to
heterozygous animals in gray and again
replicating our prior data we can see
that heterozygous animals treated with
vehicle are much more anxious than their
wild-type counterparts and interestingly
when we treat with diazepam we can see a
decrease in anxiety in the wild-type
mice but the anxiety in the GABA to one
mice didn't seem to change however both
groups showed a decrease in anxiety when
treated with the azd compound is 87 3 to
5 and here in this graph we're just
looking at heterozygous animals and
comparing the 3 groups in terms of their
percent close time and we can see
vehicle and diazepam treated
heterozygous animals are spending you
know close to 90 percent of their time
or yeah 90 percent of their time in the
closed arms and in comparison when we
treat them with a zd7 3 to 5 we see a
significant reduction we also pursued
testing some of these selective
benzodiazepines for normalizing the EEG
as well and so here again we have
baseline recordings from wild-type and
heterozygous mice and the red line here
represents our administration of ACD 7 3
to 5 and so what we can see is that
shortly after administration of azd
compound we see this powerful reduction
in Delta activity that's relatively long
costing and even though it still has a
little more power overall in this
example in comparison to wild-type
this was a significant reduction in
Delta power we can see that plotted over
here so this is fast Fourier transform
analysis again we're looking at
normalized power and frequency on this
axis so this is the Delta frequencies
and up top here we can see these are
heterozygous animals at baseline and
when treated with the azd compound they
move down and largely overlap with the
wild-type frequencies and here we're
looking at theta frequency because we
can also see some alterations in theta
as well with a ZD compound and so here
we've got heterozygous baseline and then
we can see that suppression of theta by
the ACD compound over to summarize some
of the research that we've talked about
so far the gaba-a receptor alpha 2
subunit we've shown as a preferential
interacting partner with kali biston and
this is again kind of a new finding
because we thought that Jevon was a
partner for all of the alpha 1 through 3
subunits so once we were able to
identify that kali biston was a unique
interacting partner of this portion of
alpha 2 then we decided to mutate it and
so mutation of alpha amino acids 358
through 375 of the alpha 2 subunit of
the gaba-a receptor
results in increased expression of the
alpha 2 subunit but it is miss localized
and it doesn't reach the axon initial
segment and we also see a corresponding
loss of inhibitory synapses there and so
this suggests that even though other
subunits can get to the axon initial
segment they're not sufficient to help
wire wire it up properly from the
chandelier cells so when alpha 2 can't
get there we end up losing those
inhibitory synapses onto the AIS we also
saw that a proportion of the gap r2 on
pups died during this late postnatal
period
and it was really in the range between
postnatal day ten to 25 with a peak
right around postnatal day 20 and this
is likely related to the seizures that
we observed although we were never able
to kind of directly correlate an animal
having a seizure and then seeing it died
from those t-shirts and this is an area
where we're kind of concentrating a lot
of effort now is to try to examine you
know what's happening during development
or all of the mice having seizures and
only some of them die or just a portion
of them are having seizures and also
trying to kind of examine what some of
the factors might be in whether animals
die or survive on during this sensitive
period we also found that gabart t1 mice
also exhibit anxiety and impairments in
the control of oscillatory activity in
adulthood and this was evidenced by this
huge increase in delta power in the
electroencephalogram and then we also
went on to test some novel compounds
from AstraZeneca again to see if they
could normalize the anxiety and also the
altered EEG activity and we were able to
see efficacy of an alpha 2 selective
positive allosteric modulator called a
zd7 3 - hi so just to kind of bring this
back around to human health and
neurodevelopmental disorders there is a
population of human patients with
mutations in kali biston and they
display a severe developmental syndrome
that's characterized by sensory hyper
arousal seizures hyperactivity disturbed
sleep-wake rhythm anxiety cognitive
verbal and social impairments and early
mortality and in this talk I showed you
that the Kebra - one mice have seizures
and they have enhance anxiety and they
also have early mortality and in other
studies were evaluating their sleep-wake
rhythm and looking at their levels of
activity overall as well as some of
these other domains and again what we've
seen so far is that the alpha to one or
GABA to one mice really
display common characteristics with
these patients with mutations on Kali
biston and so alpha 2 dysfunction may be
responsible for these symptoms in this
disorder and may represent a new
therapeutic target and also there are a
number of related disorders that may be
promising for treatment with alpha 2
modulators such as dravet syndrome
because again they share a lot of these
characteristics so that's kind of again
an expanding area that we're working on
now is looking at other disorders and do
they share some of these features so I
just wanted to thank Dustin who is my
number one collaborator and we have a
lot of really interesting projects that
intersect between the two lats so I feel
really lucky to have him working with me
Steven Moss who was my postdoctoral
mentor and where a lot of this work was
started hans american hermann jinlun who
contributed a lot of the biochemistry
data analyzing the interaction of alpha
2 with kali biston and Patricia
panzanella and jean-marc Richie who were
very helpful with some of the
immunohistochemistry and then Nick
Brandon and Alan cross from AstraZeneca
I met a neuroscience they contributed
novel compounds for us to test in the
animal models and I to current graduate
students are contributing to these
projects and in particular and carrying
them forward Russia Elly Rodriguez and
Austin Boren and we have a number of
really fantastic undergraduate students
that work in the lab as well and
students that are working on this
project most closely are april Contreras
and Cristina Hoya and those are the
slides that I have for today thank you
so much so if you can unshare the
presentation there we go did it work
yeah
so thank you very much it's pretty
interesting I hadn't known the details
of like all these various dub gaba
segments what is happening and all those
things which is pretty interesting to
know I have a few questions
you mentioned in the mutant there is a
miss localization right they don't go to
s observe they go to any other place
other than a s so there it is more total
receptor and it does seem to be mostly
diffuse actually not mostly diffuse
there is a diffuse population of alpha 2
subunit but when we look at Co
localization of alpha 2 with presynaptic
markers we do still see that at other
sites alpha 2 goes to synapses so we can
still see Co localization of V gap
positive presynaptic terminals and alpha
2 on the soma for example and on the
dendrites
so it seems relatively specific for the
axon initial segment synapses so they
might move to some other place to join
yeah I mean it it does seem like there
at other types of synapses and and
normally they are present at other types
of CNS is it's just that they're
preferentially enriched on the AIS and
there's also some ideas that there might
be mixed populations at different types
of synapses and maybe even within a
single receptor there might be a mixed
population of alpha subunits okay and
you had mentioned initially like the
gaba receptors like those go down with
the h second slide or so and i have a
question on that like sometimes like you
see some of these epilepsy in humans
especially in the later part like when
they're grown-ups so is it due to like I
mean like because I would think that
development has already stopped in terms
of brain development at that time so is
it because something else is happening
in the humans so you mean in the older
population yeah it's a bit complex when
people get old
one thing that starts to happen
especially in the teenage years is
there's an increase in you know head
injury and things like that and those
things can predispose to development of
seizures and epilepsy and then later in
life there's a number of complex things
that happen in terms of you know just
general dysfunction of circuitry and
when we look at GABA receptor subunit
expression alpha 2 is really high or
early in development and then goes down
into adulthood but other subunits start
lower and then go higher so it's it's
kind of a complex pattern and it doesn't
necessarily map right on to epilepsy
especially in the older adults okay and
in the new dawn like these GABA ones are
like founding it different like you
mentioned that at different places right
so as anybody else has looked into what
happens if you eliminate at other places
so there's some some relatively new work
looking at what specifies the peri
somatic synapses so John Mark Ritchie's
group has looked at a molecule called
district lichen it seems to play a
really important role for some of these
synapses that are on the cell body and
so you know they've looked at that
mostly kind of on the cell and molecular
basis and they we don't yet have too
much information about what happens in
those animals
okay I think I'm I'm exhausted with all
the questions right now so I really
thank you so much for taking part in
this hangout and I really appreciate
your support and hope I'll be presenting
this putting it on the face book and
recite which you should be able to see
within 24 hours on the main page of our
site and as soon as we are done you can
see it on our web page also thank you so
much for inviting me to do this I really
appreciate your support
thank you yeah take care